all right guys listen up i just i just  got OBS to work a couple of weeks ago  and since then i started streaming  nearly every day and switch but the only  problem is that nobody is actually much  more extreme so yeah I am really sad but  it's fine then it's cool when we have  the great time together so it'd be great  if you guys could also join the fungus  yeah it'sit's to school so basically I  stream like ass at nearly every day and  I just do random [ __ ] random making the  videos that I usually post on my channel  playing roller coaster qe3 or other [ __ ]  whatever you want and it's about I think  it's about seven no it's about 6 p.m.  UTC which would be 7 p.m. in mainland  Europe and about 4 to 5 p.m. no 43 p.m.  in the east coast and something in the  morning in the west coast or something  but basically I stream run that time  nearly every day so if you want to come  over it'd be cool piece I guess